hello everyone welcome to the biggest
ideas in the universe I'm your host Sean
Carroll this is the Q&A video for idea
number 14 which was symmetry and we have
an interesting grab-bag of different
questions that I'm gonna try to get to
this week so let's dive in the first one
comes right right down to the meaning of
what we mean by a group of
transformations remember we went through
in this imagery video about how a
symmetry is a way that you can transform
a systems physical system for example in
such a way that you've done something to
it but the end product is no different
like the triangle when you either flip
it or rotate it by 120 degrees you get
back exactly the same triangle this is
kind of an abstract notion when you
think about it you're talking about the
meaning of a transformation or a group
of transformations group both in the
figurative sense the casual sense of a
set of things but also the mathematical
notion of what do you mean by group
theory what a group means in that
context so let's in particular go right
down to the integers this is where the
question came up the question was why is
group multiplication for the integers
group multiplication actually addition
and here's a good question right so the
point here is that in group theory in
general when we have two elements of the
group and we combine them together we
call that multiplication or I suppose
you could ask us the other way around
why is what is obviously the operation
of addition known as group
multiplication in this context so the
point here is that we are thinking of
the integers in two separate ways and
that's why it gets confusing and this is
very very common in math this is one of
the reasons why both in math and in
physics or science more broadly it can
be hard to learn things because the
experts know what they're talking about
and they can use the same words in two
different ways and if you're not yet an
expert you might get confused about that
so the thing about the group idea the
idea of a group of transformations is
that we can combine them we can
transform the triangle one way and then
we can
4minute another way and we can then
forget about the fact that it was a
triangle we can just think about the set
of transformations and we can say no
matter what you act on you act on it by
this transformation and death
transformation it's equivalent to some
third other transformation remember one
of the features of a group was when you
combine two transformations together you
get a third transformation that is also
in the group so we can forget about what
we're acting on and just think
abstractly about the set of different
kinds of transformations and that is a
leap of abstraction that can sometimes
be hard to get on - so let's explicit us
make this brutally explicit by
distinguishing between the integers as a
set of things and the integers as a
group okay these are two different
things so let's say the set of numbers
the set of integer numbers that's what
we're usually familiar with okay and
let's call this n sub Z the numbers that
are actually the integers okay I'm
making this notation up this is not a
notation you're gonna find anywhere else
but this really means the numbers so
this is the set of n such that n is an
element of that dot minus 2 minus 1 0
plus 1 plus 2
dot okay the integers and they're
numbers there's an infinite number of
them there's no notion here in this set
of anything like adding them together
okay you can add that to it you can say
okay here's the integers with the
operation of addition on them but these
are not transformations this is just a
set right now okay and now we can
distinguish between that set of objects
at infinitely big set of object called
the integers and the group of
transformations
which you might call what do you want to
call it
adding the integer K let's call it okay
so that group we might write as G sub Z
okay this is now a set of
transformations this is not a set of
numbers like the numbers are two means I
have two bananas and you know I can add
one more banana to that etc this is a
set of transformation transformations
not of numbers so this is let's call it
alpha sub n is the act of adding n to a
number and so is the transformation well
let me let's write it this way alpha sub
n is the transformation such that alpha
oops let's call it alpha K is Ida called
okay up there alpha sub K means alpha
sub K of an integer N equals n plus K a
new integer okay so this is a map okay
each alpha sub K is a map from the
numbers integers to n sub Z the
numerical integers to itself for each K
you have a map says shift everything
over by K okay and then of course it
happens to be true that there is because
this is a group you can combine things
together if you have alpha sub J acting
on alpha sub K of some integer n well
that's alpha sub J acting on n plus K
which is just and put it up here equals
n plus K
plus J that's just this doing it twice
doing this notion of shifting over by an
integer twice and then you notice that
that is of course the same is doing
alpha of J plus K acting on n right
alpha J plus K is a different shift it's
a shift by the amount J plus K it is not
by itself the combination of anything
but it is equal numerically to n plus K
plus J so what we do then following up
on what I just said is we look at this
and we say the integer n on which we
were acting played no role okay it just
went along for the ride it could have
been anything at all
couldn't even been a real number but
we're gonna ignore that right now okay
so rather than writing we could write
alpha J plus K of N equals alpha J alpha
K of n that's true this is saying
shifting n by J plus K was the same as
shifting in by K and then shifting n by
J you knew this we can just write alpha
J plus K moves alpha J plus K equals
alpha J times alpha K okay now why do
you want to call it x because in this
particular example where what we're
doing is the integers then of course
we're just adding the integers
themselves together but more generally
more abstractly we're going to be taking
two transformations and combining them
composing them in fact would be the
technical term here first you do alpha K
then you do alpha J it might be the case
that these do not commute for example of
in more general circumstances that you
can't do one than the other and be
expecting it to be the same as the other
and then the first one so in the more
general group Theory context it makes
sense to call this a product of two
transformations because they won't
always commute they'll have different
properties and so forth here in the
integers it is in fact the same thing
addition and multiplication so the group
product is not multiplying numbers the
group product is taking two elements of
the group and combining them together
one followed by the other in the case of
the integers that's the same as adding
the integers themselves but that's a
special case that's not the general
feature and this is also why you will
sometimes see people write things like
so real people just write Z for either
the set of numbers or the set of
transformations so let's go back to
doing that and they will write two
copies of Z as Z plus Z or that's the
same thing as Z squared right and there
was a question like why in the world
then we write that as Z plus Z or maybe
a direct sum and the answer is just it's
the same thing in this case in this case
where it's the integers there is no
difference this all this notation means
in any of these notations it just means
two different copies two ways to shift
so this would be for example a symmetry
group on two copies of the integers so
let's say you add N and M and then you
could take one particular value and you
would shift it up both in the end
direction and the M direction that will
be the group Z twice and C squared Z
times Z whatever you want to call it
okay but really I just wanted to use
this as an excuse to really draw out
this distinction between a set of things
and a set of transformations
it's a quick leap of abstraction when
you first faced with this but it's a one
that it's one that is useful to glom on
to okay that was one question here's
another question I think this was
implicit I don't know if this is
explicitly asked but it was it came
about remember our first example of a
group was on the triangle I know when my
triangle disappeared that's too bad
here's the triangle there we go see if I
can make it look a little bit more
regular okay and one of the things we
said was that you could flip the
triangle around an axis so if we labeled
this forget what we labeled it
I know as ABC but forget what the
original order was but we can flip it
around the vertical axis right okay so
that was one thing that we could do and
some people were a little bit worried
you know don't you have to
lift at the triangle out of the plane to
do that right when you flip it around if
the triangle is part of this
two-dimensional plane why are you
allowed to do that
and that this is actually you know a
great question because it really brings
to life what assumptions are being made
and what assumptions are not being made
remember if you go back to the geometry
video that we did part of the insight
that Gauss and Riemann had is that we
can and should talk about geometry
intrinsically to the object this
triangle is clearly embedded in a
two-dimensional plane
I drew it there and if you were to
define what the triangle was you might
very well make use of the
two-dimensional plane in which it sits
embedded but when we get to this point
where we're talking about the symmetries
of the triangle and more generally the
symmetries of other things and particle
physics and quantum field theory etc
we're not imagining that it's embedded
in anything we're imagining it's an
intrinsic object somehow for the circle
so compare this to the circle for
example here's a circle is this gonna
become a circle who became an ellipse
but I think I can make it more like a
circle there we go
so the circle one way to define a circle
is to say I start with a point and I
take the set of all points some fixed
distance R from the original point from
the origin now clearly that only makes
sense if you're embedded in some
two-dimensional surface you can
generalize by the way this definition
two spheres of any numbers of dimension
the number of points the whole set of
points a fixed distance R from the
origin in n dimensions is the N minus 1
dimensional sphere but once we've done
that once we made that definition we're
now interested in features of the sphere
that do not embed depend on that
embedding likewise for the triangle up
here were interested in features of the
triangle that do not depend on the
embedding so when we say a flip okay
when we say a flip and we visualize it
is bringing it out of the try bringing
out of the plane and copying it flipping
it over well what you really are
thinking of is a map from the triangle
to a
self okay flip in the vertical direction
forget what we called this should look
at my old notes here but the point is
the thing that turns it into this
triangle BAC okay it is a map that sends
for instance this point gets set to that
point okay this point gets set to that
point
etc and the map doesn't require that we
physically lift the triangle up can move
it around it just means if you tell me
where you are in the original triangle
under the map I know where you are on
the new triangle okay so that's why
flips are just as good reflections or
whatever you want to call them when you
think about what the symmetries of these
spaces or these objects are you should
think about them intrinsically you
should try your best do not visualize
them as being embedded in something else
that can be difficult to do but that's
the goal to which we strive and one
here's a related question I don't even
think this is a question to be honest
but I think this is something I should
emphasize I said it in the original
videos but I'm going to say it again
which has to do with the non
commutativity of these transformations
you know the integers up here commute
that is to say if I do a shift by N and
then shift by M it's the same as doing
shift by M and then shift by N the
rotations do not commute so rotations
and forget about the flips for a minute
so so3 this is the set of rotations in
three dimensions okay there's a couple
questions about this one was why is it
three-dimensional which is a good
question let's get to that question
first why is this a 3-dimensional group
so the dimensionality of ASO 3 equals 3
whereas the dimensionality of so2 for
example equals 1 does not equal 2 so
what this means
so3 is rotations in three dimensions of
space for so2 it's kind of obvious that
it's one-dimensional if you think about
taking some vector in two dimensions x
and y and you rotate it by an angle
theta then there's only one
number that you need to give me give me
the number theta I tell you by how much
I rotate it okay so the question for so3
was well for so3 here I'm gonna draw
three axes X Y Z and I give you a vector
right here okay and if I want to change
that vector to something else well what
I will do is I will tell you you know if
I drop this down so I can give you
coordinates for this vector this is Phi
and this vertical vector is Theta I can
just change both Phi and theta so if I
map it to some other vector over here
okay and it's supposed to be a rotation
it doesn't look like a real rotation I
need to better better-looking rotation
here I'll rotate it this way okay so if
I can rotate this I could just rotate by
a certain amount of Phi and then again
by a certain amount of theta and I'm
done right it looks like the only
requires two dimensions to specify a
rotation in three to two numbers okay
theta and Phi or Delta Theta and Delta
Phi to specify a rotation so the there
the answer to that is that in fact when
I do so3 rotations reminder so3 I'm not
just rotating one vector I'm rotating
the whole three-dimensional coordinate
system okay so if I want to let's make a
different color I want to rotate this
somehow I might send it to something
looks like this so if this was this X
prime Y Prime and Z Prime
and this was X Y & Z and so if you go
through and well I'll show you an
example but you're gonna have to give me
three different numbers to specify how
all three of these change and that's
kind of clear from here because if I
rotate this vector to over here okay
well I can also rotate around that
vector in any way I want
while keeping the first thing the first
vector that I changed fixed so there's
two numbers that I need to change one
vector in three-dimensional space to
another vector
but that I have a whole one more degree
of freedom that says I can rotate around
that vector that is not specified by
those two numbers so clearly I'm going
to need three parameters and in this
case there are different ways to specify
what those three numbers are but you can
sort of see from the picture that you're
gonna need three different directions to
move in if you like you can think about
it as a rotation node X rotates around Y
rotation around Z and that also helps
explain why in this case so3 is non
commutative okay which in the case in
which the reason why it makes a
difference the order in which you do
operations I thought it would be fun or
useful to actually show that a little
bit more explicitly so if you have X Y Z
because there's also a little bit of
clarity is helpful in what you mean by
rotation around X rotation around Y
rotation around z so let's rotate that
stuff start with our axes here and
remember what we're doing is we are
rotating all three axes at once and
we're gonna start by let's say rotating
around the Z so let's call this our Z
and when we do all simple simplify my
life I'm gonna rotate by 90 degrees in
each case okay and one of the points I
want to make is we still have X Y Z when
we do our rotations we need to be able
to specify with respect to what right so
what I'm imagining is x y&z are fixed as
our original coordinates but we're
creating new coordinates we're
transforming XYZ into some other set of
three vectors defining different
coordinate axes so we'll make those
different colors so sorry XYZ it's still
XYZ but now we're going to rotate 90
degrees around Z so this direction is
going to be X prime this direction is y
Prime and Z remains unchanged Z prime
okay so you see what happened there you
see how X moving to where Y was Y move
to do minus X and so on and then let's
do a rotation around X and this is why
it's useful actually work out the
example because once you've done that
first rotation you might be thinking
wait a minute
when I
rotate around X do I rotate around the
original X or do I rotate around X prime
and the answer is the simplest way
that's the way the most people do it is
you rotate around the original X okay so
rx ry RZ rotations around the three
different axes are all with respect to
the originals so now we're gonna take
our yellow one and we're gonna rotate
that and we're gonna rotate it around
your original X 90 degrees so X prime
goes up to go where Z prime was so this
is now X prime Y prime doesn't change
because we're rotating its along the
direction of X and that's all rotating
along and Z prime goes to be minus y so
hopefully you can all see at home how
this is happening by rotating around the
original X 90 degrees by the way the
right hand rule comes in so if you want
to say well what is 90 degrees versus
minus 90 degrees you put your thumb
along the direction of the positive
original axis so I'm putting my thumb
along the directions direction of plus X
and that's how I know to rotate from
original Y to original Z that's what it
means
so this is what I get when I do first
our Z and then our X what would happen
if I did first our X and then our Z
let's verify to ourselves that we would
get a different answer so this is X Y Z
originally now we're gonna do our X so
still have our originals X Y Z we're
gonna make this yellow and 90 degrees
round X means that X stays the same
y is now going up here where Z was this
is y Prime and Z goes down here so this
is Z Prime and now I'm gonna do a
rotation around z comparing to my
originals XYZ and I'm gonna get what am
I gonna get I am doing this in real time
this is not practice so our Z moves
around this direction so X prime is
gonna slide over where Y is Z prime is
gonna slide over to where X's and y
prime is not going
move let's see what are the chances I
did that correctly I think I did that
correctly yeah look at that
so what you notice is when you compare
these two together these are not the
same right I did not end up in the same
place by doing first a rotation by Z and
then a rotation by X followed by
rotation by X and then rotation by Z you
get different answers so this is why
this is just a nice illustration that I
think I would be useful to make a little
bit more concrete and explicit about how
rotation groups can be non abelian can
be can fail to commute in some sense
okay then we had a question and this was
asked by a couple people a couple
different ways I'm not exactly sure what
the question is so I'm going to talk
about the idea of complex dimensions and
I think that part of it comes down to
the fact that there is always this
confusion just about the word dimensions
right we think there's two traditional
ways to think about dimensions the word
dimension and both of them are not quite
applicable here one is like the
completely weird science fictiony way
like you travel to another dimension
okay that is not what we're talking
about in any of these lectures a
dimension is always a direction you can
move in in some abstract space so the
other common notion of dimension is the
real dimensions of space right one two
three up down left right forward
backward these are not that either when
we talk about the dimensionality of
Hilbert space or the dimensionality of a
symmetry group what we're talking about
is how many numbers do you need to
specify that symmetry group or that
space what are the number of real valued
free parameters that you need to specify
exactly where you are in this space and
I said real values but but that's this
is the point in some cases it is more
useful to think about complex valued
dimensions okay so what in the world
does that mean so very quick reminder of
what complex numbers are I know you know
this if you've gotten this far already
but it's just useful to fix it into your
head we define I to be the complex unit
the square root of -1
and in fact what we really mean is in
some sense we have a two to two real
dimensional space called the real values
and the imaginary values of whatever
we're doing whatever number were
specifying and we specify this number to
be one and this number to be minus one
and then this number to be I and this
number to be minus I and then any point
in this thing called the complex plane
can be thought of as a plus I B so it's
very much like a little vector space it
is a little vector space to be honest
you have two components you have the
real part a you have the imaginary part
B and you might want to say well okay
it's just a two dimensional vector space
it's two real numbers that I need to
specify one complex number why in the
world am i calling this the complex
numbers rather than just two real
numbers what advantage do I get by
thinking of two real numbers as one
complex number and the answer is again
if you're sort of following along my
implicit guide to how to think
mathematically the answer is there's a
bit more structure on the space called
the complex plane then there is in just
a two real dimensional vector space so a
vector space it's a space of vectors
okay collection of vectors a vector
space is a set of things that can be
added together or multiplied by a number
okay so vector space is you know V is
set of things little v1 v2 etc such that
we have to find an operation v1 plus v2
and we have defined an operation alpha
times V V one with the property that
alpha times V 1 plus V 2 equals alpha v1
alpha v2 so you can add together and you
can scale by numbers that's what makes
you a vector space and when you have a
vector space you can work in components
you could have basis vectors and that
sometimes you know there's extra
structure you can add to the vector
space like what we call a dot product an
inner product can you say whether
vectors are orthogonal to each other etc
but one way or another you can always
say you can express these vectors v1 etc
as some number a times a unit vector e
hat one the put a vector sign over v1 so
you remember it's a vector plus B
another number times the unit vector e 2
etc and then you would have this picture
you know in the one direction you would
have a unit vector here he hat one and
another unit vector there he had two and
there that's a two dimensional vector
space if a and B are real numbers
elements of the real numbers then we say
we have a real vector space so when we
say real vector space we don't mean it's
an actual vector space we mean that is a
vector space where the coefficients the
components in some basis are real
numbers ok so what I gave you the
definition I didn't say where the real
numbers are not alpha or beta could be
real numbers that could be complex
numbers if they're real numbers it's a
real vector space so clearly there's a
strong family resemblance between a 2
dimensional real vector space and the
complex plane they're both in some sense
2 dimensional but there's additional
structure on the complex plane and it
comes down to this fact I equals the
square root of -1 or in other words
there is something called I squared
which equals oops my equals minus 1 so
this equation this relationship is
something that doesn't exist down here
in just two dimensional vector space
land there's no relationship between e 2
and E 1 other than they are
all factors in fact they don't even need
to be orthogonal you can have vector
spaces without an inner product without
a one dot e to even being defined as
long as they are linearly independent
you can still make this vector space but
here you have this extra fact there is a
way of multiplying numbers in the
complex plane that has this relationship
that I squared gets you to minus one I
don't want to know what to draw there
and this also comes along with the idea
of complex conjugation that I star
equals minus I so there is a map if you
like from the complex plane that flips
you around the real axis complex
conjugation takes you from a plus IB
down to a minus IB right that equals a
plus IB star so the fact that there is a
new product rule defined on the complex
plane and associated with that there's
this idea of complex conjugation that's
something that doesn't exist in the real
two-dimensional plane so the question
should in some particular cage so do you
think about things in terms of two real
numbers or one complex number comes down
to the question is there a physical
meaning to that complex conjugation or
to that idea of multiplying I by itself
and getting you to minus one okay it
turns out that in for things like
particle physics when you have all these
fields the electron field the quark
fields and so forth the Higgs field
these are most conveniently thought of
as complex valued fields not all of them
are the gluon field or the photon field
these are real valued fields the
gravitons roughly speaking a lot of the
bosonic fields a lot of them not all of
them but well let's put it this way a
lot of the what is the best way to say
it the neutral fields the neutral
particle fields usually can be thought
of as real valued and the complex ones
can be thought of as complex sorry the
the charge field
can be thought of as complex-valued
that's roughly the way it works out and
why again very roughly like don't tell
anyone I'm telling you this but a
real-valued field is has the one number
the real value okay whatever it's doing
it might be a vector so it has
components but they're just all real
valued the complex valued fields have
two different things that can go on
there real part in there imaginary part
and that roughly corresponds to being
positively charged or being negatively
charged okay being a particle or being
an anti particle that's why you need a
little bit more freedom a little bit
more information for a charged field and
the complex numbers are just right for
that okay so if I have complex value
complex vectors I would write again you
know this is exactly the same formula v1
equals a he hat one plus B he had to
with both a and B elements of the
complex numbers okay that's what it
means to have a complex valued vector a
vector over the complex numbers a
complex vector space so it's not that
the vectors change but there's more
information in them because you can meet
both the real part and the imaginary
part of each particular coefficient and
then of course you had this extra
operation you can take the complex
conjugate etc so it turns out and this
is just a little bit of extra
information you don't really need to
know but it's fun background knowledge
this idea that you generalize the real
numbers by adding this unit called I
which is in some sense orthogonal to the
real numbers and satisfies this equation
y squared equals -1 so they're related
to the real numbers in a very specific
way can be generalized not arbitrarily
but in a very very specific number of
ways and this is you know you certainly
don't know there's how many going to
explain to you what it means but this is
the this is the topic of normed division
algebras
to be honest I would not be able to give
you this precise mathematical definition
of this without looking it up but I know
what they are there's only a couple of
them a few of them they are the real
numbers real numbers so that's so a is a
real number let's say today is a real
number okay see complex numbers are
things of the form a plus bi b with I
squared equals minus 1 okay so in the
complex numbers there's the real
direction and the imaginary direction so
a single complex number is like two real
numbers then there are also many of you
will have heard of this the quaternions
I think this is a simple for the
quaternions and for reasons why we're
not gonna get into you might thankfully
you have a plus IB so you add is another
dimension maybe shed two more dimensions
rather than just one the answer is no
you have to go all the way up to four so
you have three different dimensions a
plus I B plus J C plus K D where ABC and
D are real and I J and K are these
different kinds of directions you can
move in in the quarter neonics space
so one quaternion is for real numbers
worth of information and just like I
squared equals minus one likewise I
squared equals minus one and that also
equals J squared and that also equals K
squared and that equals I times J times
K okay so these this set of rules this
is a product table right instead of a
multiplication table for I J and K and
you know that I I squared equals minus 1
K squared equals minus 1 I times J times
K equals minus 1 so you might want to
say well like what is I J what is I
times J right I would like to figure
that out do I need to give you more
information well the answer is no you
know that I
a K equals minus 1 so let me multiply on
the right by K okay okay and then k
squared equals minus 1 so this is minus
IJ and this is just minus K so therefore
IJ equals K there you go you can figure
it out
so anyway these rules give you the
attorney ins and they are they are a
generalization with complex numbers so
the point being you could have not only
real valued vector spaces complex valued
vector spaces you can have quaternion ik
pal U vector spaces and finally you can
have octo neon ik yes I'm supposed to
tell you what the symbol is right I
think it's just to know I don't know
this these never actually come up in
most physics Oh octo means and there you
have you start running out of letters
right so instead of writing ijk you
write down one which is still the number
one and then you write down e 1 e 2 dot
up to e 7 so there's hope that looks
like a 7 so there are eight different
directions you can go in eight different
real valued numbers equal one octo nyan
and then there's a rule for you know
what is e1 squared etc there's a whole
multiplication number multiplication
tables you can multiply any of the YZ by
each other and get what the answer is
the question you should be asking is how
do I know what kind of vector space I
have or what I should have what is the
mathematical structure I should be using
when I'm doing my physics problem and
the answer is it depends on what the
physics problem is so you know the fact
that Schrodinger's equation applies to
wave functions that are complex right
the wave function is a quintessential
element of a complex vector space
Hilbert space how do you know well it
turns out that's what you need to
describe the physical phenomena so there
are people who you know very sensibly
say look there are these elegant
mathematical structures quaternions octo
nians and so forth I mean it not and so
forth
these are the only normed division
algebra there you go I think that that's
the right answer you could have other
kinds of mathematical structures that do
generalize even these vaults and then
the question you ask is well what is the
physical situation you're trying to
describe there are physics-based reasons
why the Higgs boson is a complex valued
field and the photon is a real valued
field the Higgs boson that's a terrible
example isn't it because the Higgs boson
is of course the Higgs boson which
results from spontaneous symmetry
breaking after the fact is a real-valued
field that was a terrible example the
for there are four components to the
Higgs field before spontaneous symmetry
breaking and those are complex numbers
I haven't told you about that yet so
you'd have no idea what I'm talking
about so therefore you're confused but
don't worry we will talk about that
eventually better example the electron
ok the electron is a complex valued
field the photon is a real valued field
why because electrons have electric
charge an electric charge is either plus
1 or minus 1 photons do not have
electric charge photons are neutral ok
so the question is not you know here's
the math let's fit it into the physics
the question is what is the physics and
now let's look for the math that
conventionally conveniently helpfully
describes it so in noting that we're
gonna do for the rest of these videos
our quaternions wrote onehans gonna be
very helpful they could be in other
examples but we're not going to get that
far
I mean I guess I never said this out
loud but the philosophy of these videos
the biggest ideas in the universe is not
to really be very speculative you know
I'm not talking about my favorite ideas
in the world I'm trying to talk about
the ideas that have established
themselves as really really important so
the videos aren't here to speculate
about crazy ideas that I'm fond of many
which I have nor are they to sort of
chase the most recent news or the most
recent wrinkle about you know particles
being discovered and stuff like that I'm
really trying to talk in these videos
about the ideas that we know are very
very helpful trying to explain the
universe so su 3 across su 2 cross u 1
is very very helpful in trying to
explain the universe
otoni ins who knows maybe they are maybe
they're not but that they do not qualify
yet as one of the biggest ideas in the
universe by our standards here okay let
me talk about one more thing one final
thing which actually goes right in to
the fumble I just made talking about the
Higgs boson which is the idea of
spontaneous symmetry breaking now we'll
talk about this a little bit better
later on actually we'll be talking about
this I don't even know we haven't talked
about it yet
but we we mentioned it in the last Q&A
video because we talked about
topological defects remember imagine
that you have two scalar fields Phi 1
and Phi 2 with a potential V of Phi 1
and Phi 2 equaling minus mu squared Phi
1 squared plus Phi 2 squared plus lambda
v 1 to the fourth plus Phi 2 to the
fourth I think that works but anyway
what I want is to have a so-called
Mexican hat potential Phi 1 Phi 2 and
then V of Phi looks something like this
I'm drawing it here so that the minimum
is not at zero but that okay it doesn't
really matter I you just add a constant
to it plus a constant okay and then what
you notice for a potential like this
where there is a Phi squared piece that
is a negative coefficient and Phi to the
fourth piece that is a positive
coefficient the minimum of the potential
is on top of a hill sorry the center of
the potential is the top of a hill but
the minimum of the potential is down at
the brim of the Hat so there's not a
unique single point that is the brim
that is the minimum of the potential
there's a whole vacuum manifold that's
what we called this the vacuum manifold
the space of possible states of lowest
energy and what I said was reason why I
mentioned this in the last Q&A video
because the last Q&A was about geometry
and topology and I said look the vacuum
manifold in this case is a circle s1
right
it has the property that PI 1 of s1
equals Z and PI 1 is the fundamental
group it's the way that we can map
circles into the vacuum manifold and the
fact that we can map circles in a
topologically non-trivial way into the
vacuum manifold gives rise physically to
cosmic strings because if you think
here's space
here's 2d space and let's imagine that
in this region of space actually let me
draw let me draw it this way we drove up
with better here a little bit more
careful here's space and here's the
vacuum manifold of my scalar field
theory the space of all field
configurations phi1 and phi2 which
minimize the energy and the reason why
there are cosmic strings is field space
here right here is secretly I'm not to
draw the potential but this is phi1 and
phi2 and the vacuum manifold has the
property if this is the value v little v
don't ask me why it's usually called
little V Phi 1 and Phi 2 combine Phi 1
squared plus Phi 2 squared equals V
that's the vacuum manifold the set of
all possible values of Phi 1 and Phi 2
so they sit on that circle down there
now we want to do is say like let's
imagine I have a region of space which
is actually this circle okay not the
interior of the circle let me draw a
circle in space and imagine that at
every value of that circle the fields
Phi 1 and Phi 2 are in their vacuum and
volt okay so I have a point a base point
and I map it to the vacuum manifold and
if the whole circle gets mapped to just
one point in the vacuum manifold and
everything is fine everything is just
topologically trivial nothing
interesting going on but it can be
to this vacuum manifold that this region
of space gets mapped with a winding
number it wraps topologically
non-trivial e around the vacuum manifold
and what that means is that somewhere
inside here you're gonna have to climb
out of the vacuum manifold
that's the usefulness of topology in
spontaneous symmetry breaking it can be
the case that if your vacuum manifold is
non-trivial their configurations in
space which imply that you can't be in
the vacuum manifold everywhere you
cannot smoothly continue the field
values while remaining in the vacuum
manifold because they cannot be unwound
there you go and therefore you say that
here there is some energy right there
and this is just two dimensions of space
so I can just do it
I can extend in the third dimension if
this is Z direct direction then this
region of space which climbs out of the
vacuum manifold and therefore has energy
because it's sitting up here at the top
of the potential is gonna look
one-dimensional it's going to look like
a string so long story short if the
fundamental group of the vacuum manifold
is topologically non-trivial the field
theory can give you cosmic strings what
does this have to do with symmetries
well look I mean look at this potential
that I drew here I'm not I'm trying to
hide the equation I'm not exactly sure
the equations right but you can look at
the potential and there's clearly a
symmetry here right there's an so2
symmetry there's an so2 symmetry that
rotates phi1 phi2 thought of as a
2-dimensional vector in a 2-dimensional
space 2 Phi 1 prime Phi 2 prime right so
if you think of it this way you've been
drawing it like this Phi 1 Phi 2 and I
can do a little rotation to make this
Phi 1 prime Phi 2 Prime
okay I can rotate it by a little bit and
just as clearly so this is a this is a
symmetry of the theory this is not just
a that's nothing to do with spontaneous
symmetry breaking yet this is what the
symmetry is of this theory if I have Phi
1 and Phi 2 it doesn't matter what
direction I call Phi 1 and what
direction I qualify to they're both
there okay and I can rotate them the
physics is remaining unchanged so we
know that so2 itself is a
one-dimensional group so so2 it turns
out well let me say more generally
groups have topologies
that's like escalation which should be
the punchline of this what is the
topology of this group well in this case
what I mean by having a topology I mean
that for all the topological invariants
we talked about like the homotopic
groups like PI 1 etc the dimensionality
there's an answer for this group what
that is so I can of course can talk
about PI 1 of the circle how can I wrap
one circle around another one and we've
talked about you know wrapping circles
around punctured planes or spheres or
things like that I can do the same thing
with a group so I can talk about PI 1 of
so2 and it equals maps from the circle
into so2
top of the set of topologically
equivalent Maps the set of maps that can
be deformed into each other so you
probably have guessed this already but
look the action of so2 is just a
rotation here by theta by a single thing
and theta can go from 0 to 2 pi so
topologically it turns out that
topologically
so2 group of rotations in two dimensions
is equal to the circle that's exactly
what it is the set of all rotations in
two dimensions can be parameterized by
points on a circle how much if you
rotate by there you go
so therefore PI 1 of so2 equals Z it's
the integers and you might now be
thinking well oh good so the symmetry
group gave rise through the vacuum
manifold and that's why we know there
are cosmic strings not quite that simple
let me let me drive home how complicated
this can get because it can get
complicated pretty quickly here so what
about you know another subject
what about so3 well you might think you
know we have three dimensions we're
gonna rotate them so just like in two
dimensions when we rotate it around a
circle maybe in three dimensions we
rotate around some kind of sphere right
the sphere is left invariant by
rotations but that's not true that's why
we had the previous discussion about the
dimensionality a 2-dimensional sphere is
two-dimensional but so3 is three
dimensional
so3 cannot be the same as a
two-dimensional sphere and has nothing
to do with a 3-dimensional sphere right
it seemed it seems to have nothing to do
with it
so there's a long story short but let me
the point is the real point that I
wanted to get to is just because I tell
you what a group does what it acts on
doesn't mean you can tell me what it's
topology or it's geometry is right away
it turns out that I won't go into
details here but that so3 is a three
dimensional sphere with an
identification by a z2 which is to see
there's a single discrete symmetry
mapping different sides of the sphere so
it's very hard to draw a 3-dimensional
sphere imagine that instead of being
two-dimensional which it really is this
were a three-dimensional sphere okay so
if this were a three-dimensional sphere
this thing that I said divided by z2 I
mean if I take this point on the sphere
identify it as the same point
as one on the other side of the Equator
okay bike D this point identified up
there with that point at this point
right here as they didn't find it at
that point right there so it's really
just the top half of the sphere in some
sense so this is all just a lesson
trying to tell you well you know if
you're if you're watching this far in
then you're here for some of the fun
things that I'm not going to explain in
complete detail the point is that the
topology of groups is very intricate and
it becomes very complicated and the
punchline of all this is topological
defects when do we get a topological
defect like topological defect is a
cosmic string a domain wall magnetic
monopole etc it is a configuration of
the field which we know has to contain
energy in some kind of dimensional
configuration simply because of the
topology of the vacuum manifold that's
what makes it a topological defect
topological defects happen when the
vacuum manifold has non-trivial topology
how do we know what the vacuum at a fold
is here the symmetry group so2 was a
circle and the vacuum manifold was a
circle that is what will happen if you
break the symmetry entirely but
sometimes you break the symmetry partway
and not the entire way right and then
you have to think harder so the answer
is topological defects you have a
symmetry group and again I know
perfectly well I'm not giving you enough
information here to completely absorb
what's being said but maybe it is a
little hint or inspiration to go further
so imagine I have some theory with a
symmetry group G and I break it
spontaneously and what that means is
whoops spontaneously to a subgroup H
subgroup of G so a smaller group
embedded in the bigger group what does
that mean that means I have some
physical configuration
which is rotated by the symmetry group
but it's not left invariant by it so for
example very very simple example let's
imagine we have so3 okay so we have X Y
Z this is real three-dimensional space
but let's imagine it's just more
abstract than that it could be real
three-dimensional space but let's
imagine some space of fields or
something like that and let's imagine
that just like over here the field would
take a nonzero value it would point in
some direction right so here this field
if it were living right there the field
is not invariant the field value living
in the vacuum manifold changes when you
do a symmetry transformation right the
set of all field values doesn't change
it maps into itself but the specific
field value that we have in that
particular location of space does change
under the field configuration that's
when you get spontaneous symmetry
breaking so let's imagine you have a
theory that is invariant under all so3
three dimensional rotations ok but let's
imagine there's some object in the
theory whether it is a vector field or
some other set of fields which takes a
value pointing along the z direction so
in other words in empty space
ok let's imagine there's a vector field
that picks out a direction everywhere in
space so then the underlying theory is
invariant under the entire rotation
group but that rotation would change the
direction in which Z the this vector
call it V is pointing in at least some
rotations would change the direction if
you rotated around the x axis or if you
rotate around the y axis then V would
change but rotations around the z axis
leave V unchanged so there's an unbroken
sub group which is just rotations around
the z axis and that is
so2 so in this case the original
symmetry group G is so3 rotations in
three dimensions the unbroken group is
so2 these rotations that leave V
invariant and then who is a long way to
go much longer than I expected a long
way to go to get to the punchline which
is that the vacuum manifold is the group
that you start with divided by the
symmetry group that is unbroken the
unbroken group okay this is called a
quotient space and what this means is I
take the in the full set of
transformations in the original group
but then I ask can they be related to
each other by a transformation in the
unbroken sub group and if they can I
count them as one element of this vacuum
manifold this quotient space called a
quotient space for obvious reasons and
it's very much like this example we gave
here if you have a three sphere and you
identify opposite points that's quotient
anout by z2 here you would have so3 mod
so2 that would be the vacuum manifold
for this theory okay and in fact you can
actually do the math there's a some
computations involved or some more math
for you to learn it turns out that
topologically this space so3 mod so2
well what what's the simplest thing it
could be how lucky could we get right of
so3 is three dimensional group it has
this weird topology we set up here it's
as three points okay it's still three
dimensional right so2 is one dimensional
group right and it turns out that you
can you can sort of check that this
makes sense but the dimensionality of a
quotient group G divided by H is the
dimensionality of G minus the
dimensionality of H
because this is saying how many
directions are there to go in G how many
directions are there to go in H how many
are left over okay
so if you like this this makes more
sense if you write the dimensionality of
G the whole group is the dimensionality
of H the number of symmetry groups left
unbroken by this field living in empty
space plus what is left over so so3 is
three dimensional so2 is one dimensional
this quotient space this vacuum manifold
is going to be two dimensional what's
the simplest thing it could be a two
dimensional sphere and indeed it is a
two dimensional sphere that's not that
many two dimensional compact closed
manifolds that it could be so nice what
this says is if you start with so3 you
break it by some vector down to so2 then
you have a vacuum manifold which is two
dimensional
that's the sphere remember when we said
up here could you think of so3 as a two
dimensional sphere no you can't but if
you break it to so2 then the vacuum
manifold is indeed that exact two
dimensional sphere it is the set of
points that you could transform V into
by an so3 transformation that's the
vacuum manifold and so it makes perfect
sense that the vacuum manifold is a two
dimensional sphere just look at this
picture look at this what V is doing and
think about everywhere I could take it
by rotating in someplace that fills up a
single 2-dimensional sphere and that is
why you know PI one of let's just tell
you these facts PI 1 of s 2 is trivial
you can take a circle map into a sphere
you can always contract it down to a
point but pipe tune of a sphere is the
integers okay if you take a sphere and
map it to asphere a two sphere method to
a two sphere you can wind around once or
twice or 0 times or -1 times or whatever
so there are no cosmic strings in this
particular theory that I have of so3
breaking down two so2
but there are mana poles one dimensional
topological defects and in fact the same
thing the same kind of logic works for
grand unification theories in particle
physics
why do grand unified theories guts as
they're called predict mana poles well
because they imagine that you start with
some symmetry group G let's just say
it's G I'm not gonna tell you what it is
well okay it could be like su 5 or
something like that but there's lots of
things that could be some simple group
not let's just let's imagine it's not
the product of two groups because then
it wouldn't be really unified and we're
trying to grandly unify everything let's
imagine it's a simple group and then H
the unbroken symmetry group the whole
point is you imagine breaking the grand
unification group down to the symmetry
group of the standard model so we know
what the unbroken group is at SVSU three
across su 2 cross u one by the way
giving more details here there's really
a I'm gonna write this and then I'm
going to unright it there's a secret
that they never tell you but it's
actually the symmetry of the standard
model is this modulo z6 there's a z6
discreet subgroup that gets modded out
in the standard model but nobody cares
and it's not actually relevant for what
we're saying right here so let's ignore
that right now the point is that for any
simple group g mu what happened there
for any simple group g pi/2
the set of topologically distinct Maps
from a two sphere into G / su 3 cross su
2 cross u 1 is the integers Z no matter
what you do if you unify the gauge group
of the standard model the symmetry group
of the standard model into a single
simple lis transformation group then
when you break it down to the standard
model there will be a non-trivial archly
non-trivial vacuum manifold that will
allow for the existence of magnetic
monopoles that's why we know the grand
unified theories predict magnetic
monopoles and we haven't seen any
magnetic monopoles so either
grand unification is wrong or there's
some mechanism that gets rid of them
like the inflationary universe scenario
or something like that again I have not
given you nearly enough information to
understand what I've been saying for the
last few minutes but I want to give you
a hint because it's the Q&A video right
yeah in the regular videos you're
supposed to understand everything but in
the Q&A videos we can let our hair down
a little bit and just let you in on some
of the things that people think about
when they're doing this for a living
so this is the one of the one of the
reasons why - Paula G is important in
particle physics because it can predict
the existence of real physical things
according to different theoretical
hypotheses your hypothesis is there's
grand unification
you know just on the basis of topology
then you must predict the potential
existence of magnetic monopoles one of
the ways we'll see a few others how
topology and symmetry are really
important in understanding modern
quantum field theory